Pope Francis has arrived in the Moroccan
capital Rabat for a visit aimed at
furthering dialogue between religions
Francis was invited to Morocco by King
Mohammed during the two-day trip the
pontiff will meet Muslim leaders and
lead a mass for the country's minority
Catholic community interfaith dialogue
is a priority for Pope Francis joining
me now in the studio for a discussion on
this is our religious affairs
correspondent Martin GAC this is the
second visit by this Pope in as many
months two months to a Muslim country he
was in the United Arab Emirates before
all for interfaith dialogue any possible
report card at present well in the sense
I think that it's really just the Pope
and the Vatican more generally trying to
reinforce the idea that Islam is an
integral part of of the worldview of the
Catholic Church as well it's an
important player geopolitically and in
this sense it is very important for a
papacy that is very much committed to
geo political geopolitical operations at
the very same time the fact is that
Morocco is an important player in terms
of inter-religious relations I mean the
Jewish community of Morocco has been
historically very integrated communities
have the different Christian communities
and at a time in which this Vatican sees
Christian communities around their world
and around Muslim countries more
generally in a in the situation of
precariousness it takes every
opportunity the Vatican takes every
opportunity to underscore success
stories I think that that's essentially
the overall thing that we're actually
seeing the relations that are forged in
the brass of course can be very powerful
and have can have political impact okay
so the post meeting with religious
leaders he's also meeting with migrants
why is he doing that and how is that
likely to be perceived by the people of
Morocco I mean I think that the
statement itself which was that no you
know no concrete or no no solid no cell
boundary no wall will actually stop or
solve the immigration problem in many
ways a very you know forth right
expression of what the position is which
is essentially that
discussion concerning immigration
stopping immigration both in the US and
in Europe especially coming from the
more conservative or right-wing
political frames is one that essentially
this Vatican rejects and takes a
position that in fact integration or the
well-being of the people that ultimately
because of the conditions in which they
are I decide to emigrate it's something
that actually has to be taken care of
obviously maroc is an important spot in
the sort of movement of people from
Africa into Europe so it's also very
telling that talking to the Moroccans
this Pope actually chooses to underscore
this essentially pointing out that you
know if Morocco once you actually
participate in the solution of the
problem it will not be enough to help
him for say the border with Spain at
CELTA etcetera etcetera political
political solutions will need to be
found okay thank you very much so as
Martin Jack DW is religious affairs
correspondent